the u2 singer performed alongside his
band mate the edge in an underground
tube station in the capital they were
joined by a ukrainian soldier during the
gig
well afterwards he spoke to sky's mark
austin
i just wonder what you make of what you
see here
i mean we just you know it's the usual
thing you you you get out of a motorcade
um you can't ever really
have a sense of what these people have
been through
no real sense
the though it's dark the evidence around
you the the shock of the mayor's
daughter jolina this incredible juliana
come in here yeah just uh
this incredible woman here she was
telling us the story and just being
fair witnessing um
hearing witness yeah so i suppose that's
what we're here to do essentially we
were invited to come by
president zielinski what do you think of
the people who did this just fine
oh that's
that's hard that's hard
um
[Music]
i think it's
it's one man's war really
and
i think there's people in russia
will
will
younger people know what's going on and
i trust in the younger people in russia
to throw this man
um
out of his
office that was so high and is so low
right now that's me trying to be
understated